today is a very special day fam
no really i've been waiting for this day
for maybe
six months jeanie mae's baby is here and
has a name so this picture was taken
in monaco france which is why this
nursery is themed after baby jay's name
monica the big reveal was made on the
real co-host's hello honey youtube
channel where she gives fans a tour of
baby monaco's nursery that's really the
theme of the nursery is what monaco is
about family moments traveling
discussions
important
key points in my life and jeezy's life
that brought monaco here the proud mama
also shares the special meaning behind
the moniker right over here is a picture
that i took on one of my travels with
jeezy literally
where this car is right there
he turned me around
and he said
what kind of life do you want with me
what do you want to do in this life what
dreams do you have special because it's
the first place that jay and i traveled
to when we were dating and it's the
first place that we ever established
what was going on with us but jeannie
says she and her husband rapper gizi
considered other options i thought baby
jay's name should be a j name because
obviously genie and jeezy like make
sense
but
that wasn't the name that came to us on
january 11th the talk show host
announced the exciting news of baby
monaco's arrival on instagram alongside
a sweet snap of a baby blanket love can
do anything to change your life so we
have a name but genie and jeezy have yet
to reveal if it's a boy or a girl
everything i shop for had to be okay for
boy or girl even genies the real
co-hosts are still in the dark i don't
know if that's a boy or a girl we don't
and guess what no fam
we're actually going to be checking in
with genie very soon and we will have
right here on the reel a gender reveal
so be on the lookout for that and when
e.t sat down with the tv personality she
explained why she and jeezy were waiting
to find out how many surprises do you
actually have in life true this is the
ultimate one and i want to have a
gender-free planning with my husband so
everything that we're excited to do
should apply to the child no matter if
it's a boy or girl and when it came to
guessing genie and jeezy were a house
divided i will tell you jeezy straight
up thinks it's a boy he thinks that boy
okay i am still open for debate because
the emotions i know this is crazy but
expecting moms you'll get what i'm
saying you feel your baby's personality
and this is really very emotional like
the things like the feels and the
sensitivity i'm like where are the men
out here that are like that i haven't
seen one yes unless i made one dope but
like until then i don't know you think
it's a girl he thinks it's a boy i love
this i love that both of you guys think
it's the different okay and you've been
sharing the just the sweetest belly
shots i really love you guys she's got
the cutest little belly you really
really do you know i'm realizing there's
a little belly anatomy that happens when
moms see you they're judging if you're
if you're high or if you're low if it's
a boy or a girl but also i realize that
it's always been good to see it from the
front yeah you know but you can't see
this belly from the back and now that's
a good thing so they're like you i can't
even tell that you're pregnant